music
after a brief period of upheaval in
Russia
in which President Vladimir Putin's
regime was tested perhaps more than at
any time and is over 20 years in power
Focus has returned to the front lines of
the war in Ukraine I'd say the
counteroffensive has been going slowly
Ukraine's allies certainly hoped for
more progress
by this point that we've seen I can't
emphasize enough
how difficult it is for a unit to get
through this obstacle belt from hell
it's among the toughest military
operations that anybody could anticipate
here's the situation on the ground right
now and what to expect next on the
battlefield
in early June Ukraine began its
long-awaited counter-offensive with much
of the fighting concentrated in the
southern regions of zaparisa and Donetsk
in those first days there were
big armed formations pushing forward
they were using German Leopard tanks
they were using American Bradley
Fighting Vehicles the terrain in the
separation region where they're trying
to push forward is very unforgiving for
an attacking Force it's very
agricultural it's mostly very flat Open
Fields You Can See For Miles so there's
very little cover
s
then on Friday June 23rd tensions
between the Russian paramilitary
organization known as the Wagner group
and Russian military leaders boiled over
after Wagner leader Evgeni pragosian
said the Russian military had killed a
huge number of his troops in an
airstrike
but as quickly as the Revolt had started
it fizzled less than 24 hours after the
Mutiny was launched the two sides
reached what appeared to be a truce I
don't think the Mutiny has had a
significant effect of any kind on the
counteroffensive if the ukrainians were
in this kind of holding pattern
where they're probing for weak spots and
that's what they were doing before the
Mutiny and that's still what they're
doing
so the situation on the ground right now
candidly
there hasn't been a significant amount
of progress Mark kimit is a retired U.S
army Brigadier General who served in
Bosnia Kosovo and Iraq there are three
attacks significant attacks going on as
the ukrainians are trying to figure out
the soft spots
along the front the first this is down
here by bakmut it is flipped back and
forth between the Ukrainian Russian
forces numerous times if the ukrainians
are able to blow through there I think
that they would go further down to the
southeast as far as possible to the
border the second area where they seem
to be putting a lot of pressure on is
down here by zapparisha obviously not
only is the nuclear plant significant
but this also gives a breakthrough route
that takes you all the way to birdiansk
if this Ukrainian force was able to
break through to birdiance there would
be a a cutting off of the land bridge up
towards the Donetsk
there's a lot of fighting going up here
near vudavar as well same idea this
would give them a route
through danette's down to Marriott poll
or could take it straight to marry a
pole
on June 6th the Nova kahofka Dam on the
danipro river was breached releasing a
flood of water from Ukraine's largest
Reservoir the Russians fearing that this
was the number one attack route to split
off
Crimea and also get out to the water
they flooded the dam down here at
novakovka well it's starting to dry out
again and the water is going into the
Black Sea that gives the potential for
the Ukrainian forces here in Harrison to
start the attack the slow progress of
the Ukrainian counter-offensive
especially in the wake of the recent
chaos in Russia raises questions why is
the counter-offensive taking so long
and why have the ukrainians had such
limited success breaking through the
front lines
this is 20 kilometers of Hell there's
absolutely no doubt that it is probably
the toughest fighting outside of the
Cities according to general kimet part
of the reason why the counter-offensive
has been so challenging is that the
front line is about 600 miles long
what's more the Russians have had months
to prepare their defenses which are made
up of a series of layered obstacles what
the ukrainians are trying to do is find
the soft spot in that defense now this
is just not a couple of barriers the
Russians like most countries have what
they call a deliberate defense which is
a series of layered obstacles all to
make sure that the Ukrainian forces are
stopped as far forward as possible so
you have an over scale Ukrainian vehicle
here that mechanized company is first
going to hit a tank trap what a tank
trap is the whole idea is to have the
vehicle go into the Trap and then come
up and to get over and out of that he's
going to expose his underbelly right
here
the fact is that the softest spot on
this vehicle is not the front is not the
side it's not the top but it's the
underbelly and as it shows its belly it
can be engaged by direct fire weapons so
the next obstacle will be for the troops
it will be this layer of barbed wire
that the troops will be caught up in and
hear from the trench lines you have
soldiers firing anti-tank weapons
machine guns
and then what's left of that force will
try to get in and through the trench
line with both dismounted soldiers and
mounted Soldiers the vehicles and the
troops now have to cross these trench
Lines no doubt there's a lot of
hand-to-hand fighting because if the
vehicles start coming across and these
trench lines can now fire from the side
Mayhem absolute ma'am on both sides
those that do get through and there will
be very few it would probably have to be
a follow-on unit that does it through
this punched hole that they have will
then hit
the mines these little dots are
minefields should they make it through
there then they hit the Dragon Teeth
these are very very sturdy concrete
triangles they will stop a vehicle if he
tries to drive through it and again to
get over it he has to expose his belly
to get over it if this unit gets through
then they will be hit by case-mated
fixed bunkers much like you saw in
Saving Private Ryan the Russians will be
firing artillery they'll be firing
cluster Munitions they'll be attacked by
aircraft helicopters drones
and so you it is not difficult to
understand why it's so hard to break
through despite limited gains on the
front lines the Russian Revolt has
provided Ukrainian troops with a morale
boost one thing that I have heard
repeatedly from Ukrainian troops
especially the ones who are fighting in
the East was that it was much tougher
coming up against Wagner than it was
coming up against regular Russian troops
for the most part that they were more
experienced that they were better
trained that they were braver but again
they were no longer on the front lines
and they had been an assaulting force
all through the war up to this point and
right now Russia's in a defensive
posture and that's frankly that's the
easier task is defending that morale
boost needs to be seen by tangible
progress on the ground and candidly
we're not seeing it since the Mutiny
started more welcome into July 6th
interview with ABC News president
zielinski sent the counter-offensive was
going to plan
we all want to do it faster the
president told me every day means new
losses
to help push back Russian forces on July
7th the Biden Administration said it
would be providing cluster Munitions to
Ukraine we will not leave Ukraine
defenseless at any point in this
conflict period I think the thing to
watch is at some point we're going to
see large formations with dozens of
Western tax we haven't seen that and and
I think that that will be when when the
counter offensive is really kind of in
Full full swing easy